well wait sharon what about what about  jonah and beanie what do they do well  kelly first of all they're nice to me  super nice on mother's day secondly my  nickname is lord annoying so they don't  call me that on mother's day i get away  with not being called lord or noy you  get a  but they always get me something with  like mom so beanie got me this little  mom necklace and jonah got me this  little initial with an m and  obviously my name is sharon but i go  with it because i  love being a mom oh my god that's such a  got me a little am a boy thing to do  though  to be at home for mom because she feels  like enamel and gold jonathan has great  taste he has exquisite taste so  it is it is a boy thing though yeah you  raised a good man if he's a good present  giver  he's a fabulous president yeah  you